[Norvig] Here is the algorithm I was able to come up with.
Knuth calls it Algorithm P.
Other people have discovered it before him, so it's been discovered over and over again.
The idea is you just go through the deck and make 1 swap for each of the index i.
And what we swap it with gives an equal chance
for any of the items that haven't been seen yet to occur in position i.
So again, we've got our deck and we're going through 1 at a time
looking at each position.
And when we get to a general position i, we're going to swap i
with the range from i through to the end.
So we're going to pick out for this element i any one of these elements
and then swap them.
Say we pick this one. Then we would swap those 2.
And then we would move on to the next position of i.
So the very first element we pick any element in the array,
swap it into the first position,
then we look at the second element and pick any element from the second on,
swap it into that position and so on.
And so we can see that every element in the array
has an equal opportunity to appear at each position.
So the qualities of this algorithm that I like is that it's so simple and clear.
It just says in 1 statement.
It makes it obvious that each location i can have any of the elements of the deck
with equal probability.
Now, there's one part of it, I guess, which is not the most clear,
which is are we exactly right here?
Here we've got N and here we've got N - 1, and that should bother you a little bit.
Do we have this right?
In general, ranges are tricky in Python
because ranges go from--
If we say random range from i to N, it's not going all the way up to N;
it's only going to N - 1. And the same thing here.
If we say from range to N - 1, actually the biggest number there is N - 2,
but there's N - 1 of them because we include 0.
So ranges are always a little bit tricky. We can have these off by 1 errors.
We want to make sure that we got this right,
and so let's have another quiz.
The quiz is, for that statement for i in range (N - 1),
what would happen if we replaced the (N - 1) with an N?
And the options are, would that give us an index error
that we've gone too far into the deck and we have the wrong index?
Would it give us a value error from random range?
Would it tell us, "You've got the wrong number in there"?
Would it give us no error but the results would be unfair
in that 1 permutation of the deck might be more common or more probable than another?
Or would it give us no error and still be fair but maybe just a little bit slower?